[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
الملك سلمان يصدر اوامر باعفاء محافظ
الدرعيه وتكليف ابراهيم السلطان بمهام
الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه الملكيه للرياض
طيران تقول بانها سترد على مقتل ضابطين
بالحرس الثوري في سوريا في الوقت والمكان
المناسبين
وزاره الحج والعمره تعلن تدشين المرحله
الثانيه من تسجيل حجاج الداخل للموسم
القادم
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه ايضا
اكتتاب وجود الاسكان في السعوديه يقترب من
تحقيق مليار ريال بعد عشره ايام من اطلاقه
مركز اعتدال يعلن ازاله اكثر من سته
ملايين محتوى متطرف من منصه التليجرام
خلال ثلاثه اشهر
حياكم الله اصدر للملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز اليوم امرا ملكيا باعفاء محافظ
الدرعيه الامير احمد بن عبد الله ابن عبد
الرحمن كما اصدر امرا باعفاء الرئيس
التنفيذي للهيئه الملكيه لمدينه الرياض
فهد الرشيد من منصبه وتكليفه وتكليف
تكليفه وزيرا او تكليف وزير الدوله وعضو
مجلس الوزراء المهندس ابراهيم السلطان
بالقيامي بعمل الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه
بالاضافه الى عمله ومهمه الاخرى
توعدت الخارجيه الايرانيه اسرائيل بالرد
بعد اعلان الحرس الثوريه الايراني مقتل
ضابط ثاني برتبه نقيب خلال هجوم تتهم
طهران اسرائيل بشانه في سوريا فجر الجمعه
الماضيه وكانت العلاقات العامه للحرس
الثوري افادت في بيان لها بمقتل النقيب
مقداد مهقاني الذي اصيب في هجوم يقال انه
اسرائيليون على ريفي دمشق ويوم الجمعه
الفائت نقلت وكاله تسنيم الايرانيه عن
الحرس الثوري اعلانه مقتل احد ضباطه
ومستشاريه العسكريين ويدعى ميلاد حيدري في
هجوم اتهمت اسرائيل او اتهمت بشنه على
محيط العاصمه دمشق
نقلت وكاله تسنيم البحريه الايرانيه قولها
بانها ابعد طائره تجسس امريكيه من طراز
لوكيد اي بي ثلاثه انتهكت المجال الجوي
للبلاد بالقرب من خليج عمان اوضحت البحريه
الايرانيه ان الطائرات الامريكيه بعد
تلقيها الرسائل التحذيريه غادرت المجال
الجوي الايراني وعادت الى الاجواء الدوليه
اعلنت رئاسه الاوكرانيه مقتل ثمانيه اشخاص
واصابه سته اخرين في قصف الروسيه استهدف
بلده على بعد عشرين كيلو مترا الى الغرب
من باكونت وقال اندريه المكتب
الرئاسيه الاوكرانيه ان روسيا نفدت قصفا
مكثفا على البلده ما ادى لسقوط قتلى
مدنيين والحاق دمار جزئي بالمباني
اشاد الرئيس الاوكراني بصد الجيش
الاوكراني لما وصفه باكبر قوه معاديه
للانسانيه في الذكرى الاولى للعثور على
جثث مدنيين اوكرانيين في مدينه بوتشا خلال
السيطره الروسيه على المدينه وقدرت كييف
عدد القتل المدنيين به حوالي 1400 شخص
قتلوا في مدينه بوتشا العام الماضي
من كيف ينضموا الينا الصحفي محمد البابا
السيد محمد مرحبا بك معي في نشاط الرابعه
من الرياض دعني ابدا معك باعلان الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه مقتل ثمانيه اشخاص وعدد من
الاصابات ايضا كذلك في القصف الروسي حول
باقمه ما هي التفاصيل المتوفره لديك
نعم بالفعل يعني صباح هذا اليوم استخراج
سكان المدينه
التي تبعد عشرين كيلو متر عن مدينه حيث
تجري يعني الحرب الحقيقيه في مدينه مدينه
قسطنطينه استهدافها بصواريخ ثلاثه مئه
واستهدفت المباني السكنيه اربع مباني
سكنيه
عن احد عشر صاروخا مما ادى الى مقتل يعني
اصابه عدد من المدنيين حتى هذه اللحظه
حصيله القتلى هي 8 قفله وسته جرحى بينهم
ثلاثه في حاله خطيره يعني فرق الاسعاف
عندما وصلت الى يعني مكان تساقط
وخاصه يعني احد المسعفين المشهورين في
اوكرانيا سعيد وسمايلو الذي يعني وثق
عمليه انقاص احد احدى المسنات التي تعرض
منزلها لسقوط صواريخ مما ادى الى تدمير
الشقه بشكل كامل وايضا يعني وجدت عدد
كانت مرميه في الطريق بجانب المبنى
هناك
من المبنى ولكن تساقط الصواريخ ويعني
الشظايا ادت الى مقتل هؤلاء المدنيين ايضا
مدينه
تتعرضت لقصف بصواريخ باليستيه صباح هذا
اليوم ومساء امس مما ادى الى ايضا سقوط
مدنيين
ايضا مدينه
الان الجانب الروسي القوات الروسي على
خلال اليومين الماضيين بدات باستهداف تلك
المدن بصواريخ بعيده المدى من المناطق
التي تسيطرت عليها روسيا في مقاطعتي
لوجاست او من العنف الروسي من مقاطعه
الجانب الاوكراني يعني
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه اعلنت بشكل رسمي سقوط
وجرح سته اخرين وايضا الجيش الاوكراني بدا
يكثف عمليته في المحيطه لمدينه
منعز ان تكون يعني هذه الضربات الصاروخيه
استنباط لمحاوله تقدم للق
وات الروسي وهذا هو السؤال يعني فعلا هل
تعني هذه الضربات الروسيه انها بدايه لاي
هجوم روسي مكثف متوقع خلال الايام
القادمه في هذه المناطق الشرقيه من يعني
وخصوصا فيما يخص ايضا باقمه التي تدور
فيها المعارك منذ اشهر محمد
ولكن يعني بحس
ب يقولون ان روسيا الان بدات تسعى لفتح
جبهات اخرى لتثبيت قوه الدفاع الاوكرانيه
مثلا يعني
تعرضت لهجوم كان هناك محاوله من الجيش
الروسي للتقدم ويعني السيطره على بعض
المناطق التي
سحبت
ايضا المدينه
عليها هجوم كبير وعميق خلال
الفتره لا تزال دفاعات الاوكرانيه
ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه توسيع يعني منطقه
القوه الدفاعيه التي حتى هذه اللحظه
الصامته على طول خطوط الدفاع يعني مثلا
مدينه
بحوالي ثمانيه اشهر من هجوم كبير وضخم
اضافه الى هجوم اعلامي ايضا كبير لا تزال
القوات الاوكرانيه تسيطر على الاجزاء
الاكبر او المساحه الجغرافيه الاكبر في
مدينه
الشكر الصحه في محمد البابا من العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف شكرا جزيلا لك
وجه رئيس مجلس الامه الكويتي مرزوق الغانم
دعوه لعقد جلسه المجلس العاديه يومي
الرابع والخامس من ابريل الجاري وتعتبر
الجلسه اول جلسه لمجلس 2020 المنحل وذلك
بعد حكم المحكمه الدستوريه بعودته بقوه
القانون حيث يتضمن جدول الاعمال اداء
الوزراء من غير اعضاء مجلس الامه اليمين
الدستوريه حسب النص واحد وتسعين من
الدستور وفي شان اخر بالبرلمان بدات لجنه
التشريعيه اليوم مناقشه انشاء المفوضيه
العليا للانتخابات وذلك حسب تغريده للمجلس
على حسابه على تويتر
الرابعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل
الرابعه تزور منازل جود الاسكان في
السعوديه وترصد وابرز تجهيزاتها
للمستفيدين
حياكم الله من جديد على قناه وزاره الحج
والعمره عن تدشين المرحله الثانيه من
تسجيل حجاج الداخل بهدف اتاحه الفرصه لمن
سبق لهم الحج قبل خمس سنوات او اكثر
واوضحت الوزاره ان الفرصه متاحه للمواطنين
والمقيمين الذين لا تقلوا اعمارهم عن
اثنتي عشره عاما وذلك ابتداء من منتصف
الشهر الهجري القادم
معنا هاتفيا من مكه المكرمه نائب وزير
الحج والعمره الدكتور عبد الفتاح الدكتور
عبد الفتاح حياك الله معي في نشاط الرابعه
من الرياض هذا الاعلان هذه المرحله
الثانيه ايضا من تسجيل حجاج الداخل كيف
تسير ما الفرق بينها وبين المرحله الاولى
ايضا كذلك لماذا قسمت على مراحل
يا هلا حياك الله اخوي نايف ولجميع الساده
السيدات المشاهدين طبعا نحن وزاره الحجر
العمره اطلقت منذ وقت مبكر مرحله التسجيل
لحجاج الداخلي المقيمين ومواطنين لفتره
طويله جدا قبل موسم الحج هو استعدادا
للمبكر لجميع اعمال الحج بما في ذلك
التسجيل وهو خطوه جدا مهمه وكانت المرحله
الاولانيه اعطينا الفرصه الاولى لمن لم
يسبق له الحج قبل ذلك واستمرت منذ فتح
البوابه في يناير
في بدايه شهر يناير الى 10 رمضان وكان
مقتصره فقط على من لم يسبق له الحج قبل
ذلك المرحله الثانيه وهي ادخلنا شريحه
اخرى ثانيه وفئات اخرى ثانيه من الراغبين
لاداء الحج وهم من قام او ادى الحجر قبل
خمس سنوات
وينطبق عليه جميع الشروط الاخرى الثانيه
الشروط الخاصه بالشروط الصحيه وبالتالي
نحن يعني وازلنا بين الاشتراطات الاولانيه
والاشتراكات الاخرى ارقام المرحله الاولى
وعدد المسجلين ايضا في الدكتور عبد الفتاح
طبعا ولله الحمد الى الان احنا تجاوزنا
75% من الحاره انشغال لجميع المقاعد
المحدده لحجاج الداخل ونحن تقريبا مرحله
ثانيه سوف تفطر 25% المتبقيه لها ان شاء
الله كم عدد المقاعد اصلا دكتور عبد
الفتاح عدد المقاعد اول ما فتحنا البوابه
في حدود 180 الف حاج من الداخل من
المقيمين والمواطنين
استكملتم فيها او منها 75% في المرحله
الاولى وخمسه وعشرين في المئه ستكون في
المرحله الثانيه اللي هي المرحله اللي
علمتوا عنها اليوم
نعم صحيح طبعا هو اكيد نحن بهذه الطريقه
يعني وازلنا بين الطلبات الاولانيه كما
يعلم الجميع انه الحج طبعا عدد الراغبين
لاداء الحاج اعداد كبيره جدا تفوق المعروف
وبالتالي نحن وضعنا الشرطه الاولاني اللي
هو لم يسبق له حج فاعطانا كافيه يعني اكثر
من اربع شهور تقريبا
للتسجيل الان الاماكن الشاغره المتاحه
المتبقيه هي ستترك لمن سبق له الحج يمكن
قبل 15 سنه او قبل عشر سنوات او 20 سنه ان
احنا نحتفظ بالسجلات جميع من ادى الحاج
السابقا ويكون في هناك تنظيم داخلي داخل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وكم تبقى من من
المقاعد رقميا دكتور عبد الفتاح مش نسبيا
يعني نحن لو تحدثنا عن تقريبا 25% نتحدث
على اكثر من 40 الف
مقعد ما زال متاح
للتسجيل هذه السنه ان شاء الله طبعا نحن
نتوقع طبعا العددنا نحن نذكر عدد كبير لكن
احنا نتوقع انه سينتهي تقريبا في خلال
الايام القادمه ولهذا السبب نحن بدانا
الاعلان بوقت مبكر بان نحن سنتيح الفرصه
لمن لم يسبق له الحج
يعني التسجيل كتسجيل بياناته في المنصه
نسك وفتحناه في الوقت المحدد الى على
النادي جميع قبل عده اسابيع يعني يا دكتور
اليوم امام حجاج الداخل
يعني دعنا نقول فترتين للتسجيل الفتره
الاولى انتهت الفتره الثانيه هذه ستكون هي
الفتره الاخيره لن تفتح بعدها الباب
لتسجيل حجاج الداخل وتكتفه بعدد 180,000
صحيح ولكن نحن مستمرين طبعا كما يعلم
الجميع انه بعض
يحدث له اي ظرف طارئ يلغي حجزه وبالتالي
نحن نطيح الفرصه لاعاده الحجز لاشخاص
اخرين راغبين لحملات محدده وبالتالي سيتم
يعني استمرار فتح البواب لان هي بوابه
الالكترونيه تفتح بشكل الكتروني ولا يكون
في تدخل يعني من وزاره الحج العمره في
عمليه
التسجيل او الحجز فكن تكون كلها الكترونيه
فحنستمر ان شاء الله باذن الله حتى نهايه
ذو القعده لكن لن نضمن حقيقه تواجد او
توفر المقاعد حتى ذلك الوقت فنحن نتوقع
يمكن تقريبا في في شوال تكون انتهت كل
المقاعد المحدده لهم وفي نفس الوقت يعني
نحن اعطينا امكانيه لدفع التكاليف الخاصه
بحمله الحج عن طريق التسجيل الالكتروني
والدفع الالكتروني بطريقه جدا سهله ومرنه
من عده
قنوات
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من مكه المكرمه نتحق
بهاتفي النائب وزير الحج والعمره الدكتور
عبد الفتاح نشاط
خصصت وكاله التفويج واداره الحشود برئاسه
شؤون الحرمين اكثر من 400 موظف ميداني
مؤهل ومدرب على مهام تنظيم دخول وخروج
وتنقل المعتمرين والزائرين داخل المسجد
الحرام وذلك عبر ممرات ومسارات وابواب
خصصت لخدمتهم ووفق معايير ونسب تراعي
الخطط التشغيليه واوقات توافد قاصدي
المسجد الحرام
[موسيقى]
مع دخول شهر رمضان يفيد الى الحرم المكي
اكثر من مليون و200 الف معتمر ومصلي يوميا
بعدها تشغيل الحرم المكي هذا الموسم بكامل
الطاقه الاستيعابيه ما جعل رئاسه الشؤون
الحرمين والقطاعات الامنيه المختصه باداره
الحشود تعمل وفق خطط نوعيه لتبطي عمليات
التدفقات البشريه وادارتها تخطيط ليس لخطه
واحده الخطه للطوارئ خطه وقت خطوره
الامطار خطه الطوارئ وقت كان زياده
الكثافه العدديه بعد كل صلاه يتم فتح صحن
المطاف مباشره يعني اثناء الصلاه يتم فتح
الحواجز مجرد ما المعتمرين يصلون في الدور
الارضي او في المناطق الخلفيه من الدور
الارضي على طول بعد الصلاه بامكانهم
التوجه مباشره الى صحن المطر
14 مسارا بالمسجد الحرام لدخول وخروج
المعتمرين والمصلين وكوادر بشريه مؤهله
تدير المسارات وعمليات التفويج الى صحن
المطاف اضافه الى مراقبه الكثافات عبر
غرفه العمليات والتاكد من ثلاثه التنقل
للمعتمرين اثناء اداء النسك صحن المطاف
الدور الارضي للمعتمرين الدور الاول وسطح
المطاف
للمعتمرين والمصلين الساحات الخارجيه
والتوسيعات السعوديه الثالثه بساحاتها
للمصلين هناك فئه من المعتمرين يرغب في
صلاه القيام مثلا او صلاه التراويح هناك
بعض المساحات تم تخصيصها في صحن المطاف
وفي الدور الارضي في المناطق الخلفيه
لصلاه المعتمرين خصصت وكاله التفويز
واداره الحشود بالرئاسه العامه اكثر من
400 موظف ميداني مؤهلين ومدربين على مهام
تنظيم دخول وخروج وتنقل المعتمرين
والزائرين داخل المسجد الحرام وذلك عبر
ممرات ومسارات وابواب جهزت لخدمتهم ووفقا
معايير ونسب تراعي الخطط التشغيليه
من الحرم المكي سلطانه السلمي العربيه
استفاد اكثر من تسعه ملايين معتمر وزائر
من الخدمات المقدمه في الحرم المكي خلال
شهر رمضان حيث ساهمت خدمات الارشاد
الميكاني بلغات العالميه بخدمه اكثر من
650 الف معتمر كما استفاد اكثر من 980 الف
مستفيد من الخدمات التطوعيه المتنوعه
بالاضافه الى استفاده حوالي 32 الف قاصد
من ذوي الاعاقه في المواقع المجهزه بخدمات
تناسب احتياجاتهم
من الحرم المكي مراسل العربيه نصفيان هاني
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض اكثر من تسعه ملايين ونصف مليون
معتمر منذ بدايه شهر رمضان حتى
حتى اليوم يعني الثلث الاول من رمضان كيف
هي الصوره لديك كيف تجري كل التجهيزات
الخدمات ايضا المقدمه لهم المعلومات
والارقام ايضا ابرزها
نعم اهلا بك نايف واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه نعم العدد قابل للزياده خلال
الفتره المقبله والايام المقبله وكذلك
اليوم سوف يزيد هذا العدد يتوقع ايضا
اليوم ان يصل عدد المعتمرين والزوار الى
المسجد الحرام اكثر من مليون و 200 الف
مصلي وكذلك معتبر سوف يكتمون
لهذه الليله وبذلك سوف يرتفع العدد الى
اكثر من عشره مليون ونصف المليون معتمر
وكذلك زائر الكثافه العدديه ورغم الكثافه
العدديه الا ان عمليه التنظيم من ضمن
الخطه التشغيليه التي خططت لها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين مع قوه امن الحرم وقوه امن الحج
والعمره تسير وفق ما خطه له هذا هو صحن
المطاف ولعله هذه الفتره هي فتره الذروه
التي الان
تكثف او يكون فيها العدد بالنسبه
للمعتمرين الذين يق
في في طواف او في صحن المطاف يزيد العدد
بشكل اكبر واضافه الى هذا العدد ونحن الان
نواكب المعتمرين على صحن المطاف هناك ايضا
ادوار خصصت وطوابق اخرى خصصتها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين من اجل ايضا المعتمين الذين سوف
يرغبون بالطواف في الطوابق الاخرى ايضا
هناك طوابق خصصت للعربات المتحركه
والكهربائيه التي خصصتها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين اضافه الى هذه الاعداد ونحن نتحدث
هناك خدمات اخرى وفرتها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين من خلال خدمات صحيه وكذلك خدمات
التنقل وخدمات مياه زمزم وخدمات التعقيم
نتحدث اليوم انه تم توزيع اكثر من 600 الف
او اكثر من 600 الف نعم من عبوه من مياه
زمزم فقط للمؤتمرين داخل صحن المطافي في
المنطقه التي نتجول فيها نتحدث ايضا عن
عدد مستفيدين استفادوا من التوعيه
الميدانيه بلغوا اكثر من مليون وثمانمائه
الف مؤتمر وزائر استفادوا من عمليات
التوعيه من خلال التوعيه الميدانيه سواء
في ارشادهم او كذلك في معرفه اركانهم او
كذلك المناطق التي يتوجهون اليها لا ننسى
ان هناك اكثر من 51 لغه وفرتها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين استفاد من هذه اللغه او من هذه
اللغات اكثر من 600 الف مؤتمر وزائر
ونتحدث عن هذا هؤلاء هم من الذين قدموا من
الخارج في الكاميرا الاخرى والتي ايضا هي
خاصه بالعربيه وترصد الشكل الكامل للكعبه
والاعلنا نرى ايضا حركه الطواف وحركه
المعتمرين والزوار في الكاميرا الثانيه
اضافه الى هذه الكاميرا التي هي تدور بين
يدي زميلي سعود العلي وهو يقوم
بالتجول مع
المعتمرين داخل صحن المطاف لنقوم برصد
حاله المعتمين وشاهدنا الحركه السلسه التي
يقوم بها المعتمين الاثناء فتره الطواف في
صحن المطاف يعطيك العافيه يا هاني انت
وسعود شكرا جزيلا لكم على هذه الصوره
الجميله من الحرم المكي مراسل العربيه
هاني الصفيه شكرا لك يعني
تجاوز اجماليه ومبالغ الاكتتاب في حمله
جود الاسكان في السعوديه 900 مليون ريال
ما يشكل اكثر من 92% من هدف الحمله والذي
يبلغ مليار ريال لتامين
3500 مسكن للاسر الاشد حاجه وكانت الحمله
والتي انطلقت في الاول من شهر رمضان
الحلقه طرحت مئه مليون سهم بقيمه عشره
ريالات لكل سهم ليصبح بذلك اكبر اكتتاب من
خيري في العالم
ينضم الينا هاتفيا عمر الوهيب المدير
التنفيذي لمنصه جوده مرحبا بك معي في نشاط
الرابعه من الرياض بدايه يعني دعنا نسال
عن
القيمه كم وصلت حتى هذه
اللحظه لمنصه جود الاسكان هي قاربت حتى
هذه اللحظه الرقم المستهدف وهم مليار ريال
لكن بشكل دقيق كم وصلت الارقام حتى الان
او الرقم
اهلا وسهلا حياك الله استاذ نايف
والمشاهدين الكرام وشكرا لقناه العربيه
تحت هذه الفرصه اليوم في اكتساب الجوده
الاسكان الذي يعني كان بدايه انطلاق شهر
رمضان المبارك وبتدشين يتبرع خادم الحرمين
الشريفين وسمو ولي العهد وتوالي كذلك عط
اهل الخير والمانحين
واصحاب الجود وصلنا هذا حتى هذا اليوم الى
927 مليون ريال لنحقق بذلك 92% من
المستهدف العام لهذا الاكتتاب وهو مليار
ريال خلال شهر رمضان نعم كم عدد المساهمين
في هذا في هذه الحمله وفي هذا الاكتتاب
ايضا سيد عمار
حنا عندنا شركات او الكبار المانحين وهم
يقدمون عطاءات من خمسه مليون ريال واكثر
وايضا لدينا الافراد احنا نتكلم عن كبار
المانحين نتكلم عن تقريبا اكثر من 50 مانع
قدموا عطاءاتهم لمنصه جود الاسكان او
الاكتتاب جود بالتحديد وايضا عندنا
متبرعين للافراد الذين
قاربوا الى تقريبا 200 الف متبرع تم اجراء
عمليه تبرعهم من خلال منصه جود الف متبرع
ولدينا اكثر من 50 يعني شريك
من مبالغ اكثر من 5 او كبار المانحين طيب
خلينا نحكي على فكره فكره الاكتتاب سيد
عمار هذه الفكره اللي طبقتوها هذا العام
كيف بدات يعني هذه الفكره كيف نفذت ايضا
اوجد وهك
طبعا منصه جود الاسكان رسالتها دائما هو
الابتكار لتحقيق التكافل المجتمعي فدائما
اذا وجد الابتكار يكون هناك يعني التفاعل
مع من المجتمع لتوفير الحلول الاسكانيه
للاسر شديده الحاجه فهذه هذا هو دائما
رساله الخاصه بمنصه جوده الاسكان والتي
يعني صارت عليها من بدايه من انطلقتها قبل
ثلاث سنوات في كل شهر رمضان يكون هناك
حمله مختلفه وطريقه جديده لجلب العطاءات
اهل الجود لتسكين هذه الاسر شديده الحاجه
كانت هذه السنه هي حمله اكتساب جود وهي
يعني محاكاه للاي بي او والطرح للاسهم
فكرتها ان يتم التحفيز من خلال العدد من
الاسهم التي يعني تهدف الى تسكين 3,500
اسره الجدوى كما ترى ولله الحمد هي جدوى
ناجحه يعني كان كنا نستهدف مليار ريال
خلال شهر اليوم نتكلم عن 92% من المستهدف
تم تحقيقه خلال اول 10 ايام فهذا يعني يدل
على النجاح الفكره وايضا تفاعل المجتمع
اصحاب الجود والعطاء الكبير وبالتالي هذا
الحدث تحقق بشكل سريع في الايام العشره
الاولى من شهر رمضان تقريبا حتى الان يعني
احنا 92% هل يعني ذلك انه ممكن
يرتفع هذا المستهدف وبالتالي ايضا حتى
يعني ترتفع
المستهدف
المساكن من 3500 لعدد اكبر ايضا كذلك
الحمله من مليار الى رقم اكبر سيد عمار
بالتاكيد الهدف من السجوده هو توفير
المساكن للاسره شديده الحاجه لذلك اليوم
فكره الطرح او فكره اكتتاب جود هي
لاستمرار هذه العطاءات وايضا لجلب المزيد
من الشركات لتحقيق الهدف في تسكين هذه
الاسره جزيل الشكر الرئيس التنفيذي او
المدير التنفيذي عفوا لمنصه جوده الاسكان
من الرياض عمار الوحي شكرا جزيلا لك
تمثل منصه جهد الاسكان مثالا حقيقيا لجهود
التكافل الاجتماعي في السعوديه حيث وصلت
اكثر من 36 الف مسكن لعوائله كانت تعاني
بسبب عدم تملك السكن مراسل العربيه زار
عددا من الاسر التي حصلت على مسكن منذ
سنوات
جود الاسكان منصه الكترونيه انعكس اثرها
على 36 الف مستفيد حصلوا على مسكن ملائم
بعد ان ظل السكن حلما يراودهم طوال حياتهم
ام علي عاشت طوال حياتها في منزل المستاجر
وامسد تمتلك شقه ازاحت عنها عناء اثقل
كاهيلها الاول كنت صراحه جار وما اجار
تاعبني مره حتى عيالي ما كان لهم مصروف
ولا لهم مدخل ولا شيء كان يلا نوديهم
المدرسه حتى احيانا انه ما اوديهم يقعد
اسبوع اسبوعين ما يروحون المدرسه كلموني
وقالوا لي انت حصلت على شقه من الاسكان
قلتي نعم قالت تحبين تمتلكينه قلت له ايه
خلاص سوى كل شيء
واعطوني الصك تعيش ام احمد في هذا المسكن
منذ سنتين غيرت مشاريع وجود الاسكان
حياتها وحياه ابنائها بعد تملك منزلهم
في الدخل
تطلع عليهم سنه ب 16 الف وانا كان ما عندي
الا الضمان داخلي واولادي كلهم طلاب
يدرسون بنات والحمد لله لما قالوا قدموا
تحصلون بيوت يعني
بلاش معي يشيلون من الضمان
والحمد لله سينضم للسيدتين وابنائهم ثلاثه
الاف وخمسميه اسره من الاسر الاكثر
احتياجا في السعوديه بعد اطلاق مبادره
اكتتاب جودي الاسكان الخيري التي حققت
ارقاما قياسيه من كبار المساهمين في ظل
استمرار الاكتتاب فيما تبقى من ايام شهر
رمضان
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض
في السعوديه اعلنت وزاره الموارد البشريه
عن توطين دفعه جديده من المهن منها اداره
المشاريع ومهن المشتريات والمبيعات
بالاضافه الى منافذ انشطه التزيين
والخياطه النسائيه وذلك على عده مراحل في
جميع انحاء السعوديه في طوطين المهن
السعوديه والذي جاء بهدف توفير فرص العمل
ورفع مستوى كذلك
المشاركه للمواطنين في سوق العمل
ومن الرياض ينضم الينا المهندس ماجد
الضحوي وكيل وزاره المواد البشريه للتوطين
مهندس ماجد حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض يعني
انخفاض اولا تاريخي وغير مسبوق في نسبه
البطاله في السعوديه
يتزامن مع هذه القرارات الجديده ايضا
للتوطين نريد الحديث عن ابرزها ولماذا هذا
التوقيت
وشكرا على الاست
ضافه كما ذكرت انخفاض تاريخي غير مسبوق ما
كان يتقاتلون توفيق الله سبحانه وتعالى
ودعم القياده الرشيده وتوافر توافر الجهود
بيننا وبين الجهات الاشرافيه ومثانه
الاقتصاد السعودي وايضا كفاءه ابناء وبنات
الوطن كما ذكرت نعمل البشريه على خارطه
طريق اعلنا عنها سابقا في توقيت عدد توطين
عدد من الانشطه والمهن والمناطق واليوم
نشهد دخول حي التنفيذ لانشطه البريد ونقل
نقل الطرود
وتوطين الرؤساء التنفيذيين في هذا النشاط
وايضا نشهد دخول حي التنفيذ المبيعات
المهن الاجهزه الطبيه واطلقنا ايضا عدد
مهم من قرارات التوطين التي تشمل مثل ما
ذكرت اداره المشاريع ونهل المشتريات ومن
اهل المبيعات
الشحن والتي نشرت فيها نمو اقتصاديه
عاليا وتوفر فيها عدد مناسب جدا من ابناء
وابنات الوطن التي اللي ان شاء الله
يشغلون هذه المناصب بكفاءه واداره عاليه
ممتاز خليني يعني اسال عن تمكين راس المال
البشري في سوق العمل بالنسبه لكم في
الوزاره مهندس ماجد كيف تنظرون اليه كيف
يعني هي الخطوات المؤشرات ايضا
كيف تقيسونها في في هذا الاطار تمكين راس
المال البشري في سوق العمل السعودي مره
الحقيقه العدد كبير من البويدرات في تمكين
راس المال البشري طبعا اطلقت الوزاره وحده
استشراء في العرض والطلب والمعنيه بتخطيط
القوى العامله مع الجهات الاشترافيه
ودراسه
الاستراتيجيات القطاعيه حتى يكون هنالك
استقراء واضح للمهارات اللي يحتاجها سوق
العمل اطلقت الوزاره ايضا مبادره الم
جالس
المعايير المهنيه
والمتطلبات المهنيه لكل لكل قطاع وايضا
هنالك حزمه كبيره من الممكنات المعنيه
بالتدريب فاطلقت الوزاره برنامج مسرعه
المهارات وبرنامج قسائم التدريب وبرنامج
التدريب على راس العمل
وصندوق الموارد البشريه داعم كبير للتدريب
وتجسير ابنائه وبنات الوطن اما
بتدريب متخصص او تدريب عام يساعد من دخول
الى سوق العمل بكفاءه عاليه شكرا جزيلا لك
من الرياض المهندس ماجد ضحوي وكيل وزاره
الموارد البشريه للتوطين
رابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
انفاق المستهلكين في السعوديه يقتربوا من
المئه مليون ريال في فبراير الماضي
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد اعلن المركز العالمي
لمكافحه الفكر المتطرفه اعتدال ومنصه
تيليجرام ازاله اكثر من سته ملايين محتوى
متطرف وذلك من يناير وحتى مارس من العام
الجاري المزيد مع الزميله العنود العبدلي
خلال ثلاثه اشهر فقط ازال مركز اعتدال
اكثر من سته ملايين محتوى متطرف على منصه
تيليجرام حيث كشف تقرير للمركز العالمي
لمكافحه الفكر المتطرفه عن ازاله عشرات
الاف من المنشورات الداعيه للتطرف لعدد من
المنظمات الارهابيه وذلك بالتعاون مع منصه
تيليجرام خلال الربع الاول من العام
الجاري كما كشف المركز عن اغلاق حوالي
2000 قناه استخدمت في بث وترويج افكار
متطرفه تعود لتنظيمات داعش والقاعده وهيئه
تحرير الشمس تمكنت مشاهدينا اعتدال من رصد
النشاط الرقمي المتطرفي لتنظيمات الثلاث
باللغه العربيه على منصه تيليجرام حيث تمت
ازاله اكثر من مليونين و700 الف محتوى
متطرف يعود لهيئه تحرير الشمس وحوالي
مليوني محتوى متطرف في اكثر من الف قناه
تعود لتنظيم داعش
لتنظيم القاعده الارهابي مشاهدينا اكثر من
مليونين و400 الف محتوى متطرف التاسع من
يناير الماضي ووفق تقرير اعتدال شهد اعلى
نشاط لبث المحتويات المتطرفه عبر
التليجرام لتنظيمات الارهابيه الثلاثه حيث
تجاوز 400 الف محتوى متطرف خلال يوم واحد
فقط فيما سجل في السابع والعشرين من مارس
الماضي اعلى معدل لانشاء قنوات متطرفه
لتلك التنظيمات حيث وصل عددها لاكثر من
مئه قناه في يوم واحد التعاون المشترك بين
المركز العالمي لمكافحه الفكر المتطرف
ومنصه التليجرام مشاهدينا يتواصل للعام
الثاني على التوالي ليصل عدد ما تم ازالته
من فبراير عام 20 22 حتى الايه الى اكثر
من 21 مليون محتوى متطرف كما تم اغلاق
اكثر من 8600
قناه متطرفه
مدينه الطائف غرب السعوديه باجواء خاصه في
شهر رمضان حيث تزين الفونيس شوارع واسواق
المدينه لاسيما المنطقه التاريخيه والتي
يمتد عمرها لمئات السنين
ومن الطائف معنا مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي عبد الرحمن مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في نشاط الرابعه من الرياض ما شاء
الله عليك يا عبد الرحمن انا ما اعرف يعني
احنا بعشر رمضان وانت خلصت كل المناطق ما
اعرف يعني يوم 30
كيف الاجواء في الطائف
انا والله خايف اطلع برا السعوديه
ههه هنا الطائف هنا الاجواء الجميله هنا
الورد وهنا الطبيعه هنا الخضروات والفواكه
هنا التاريخ والشعر والادب وعكاظ هنا
المتاحف هنا مصيف الملوك والقاده الطائف
دائما جميله وتزداد جمالا نايف في شهر
رمضان سادع زميلي ناصر ياخذنا جوله في
طائفه التاريخيه او سوق البلد كما يصح كما
نشاهد هذه الفوانيس الجميله التي تزينت
فيها شوارع السوق البلد او طائف التاريخيه
لا اكثر من اسم نايف طبعا وفيها الكثير من
الساحات ومن المحلات من محلات العسل
والسمن وايضا العطاره والعطورات والادوات
المنزليه الملابس طبعا في شهر رمضان رغم
يا نايف وجود المولات والاسواق لان اهل
الطائف يفضلون دائما يجون هنا البلد
ويتقضوا لشهر رمضان ويستمتعوا بالاجواء
الجميله واللطيفه طبعا هذا المكان ايضا
بالقرب من مسجد تاريخي
مسجد تاريخي طبعا بالقرب منه مسجد العباس
وايضا لا تنسى نايف انه المعتمرين وزوار
الحرم المكي ياتون الى الطائف بعد انتهاء
العمره ايضا للاستمتاع بالاجواء نشاهد
ايضا هنا الورد الطائف في نايف طبعا
يبيعوه بهذه الطريقه بالاكياس لنثره بين
الملابس او في البيت وايضا ينباع زي
الطريقه اهل جيزان بالفل كعقد
للزوار طبعا ايضا هنا في الطائف وجود
الخضروات والفواكه الان موسم التوب وموسم
البرتقال وموسم الموز بعد شهر حيكون موسم
المشمش وبرشومي
بمواسم كثيره وطبعا بضائع متنوعه هنا في
السوق نايف ابرز ما يميز البلد هنا في
الطائف هي الحفاظ على تاريخها والمباني
هناك عدد من المباني تم ترميمها عمرها
اكثر من 50 سنه لكن الترميم لم يغير روح
المكان وروح التصميم الطائفي للمباني ايضا
فيما يتعلق بالاسواق الشعبيه هنا بالقرب
من هذا السوق هناك سوق الخميس الذي عرف
قديما طبعا بانه التجار المواشي والاغنام
ياتون الى هذا السوق الخميس لبيع البضائع
ايضا هناك سوق الهجله ايضا برحت مسجد
الهادي ايضا هناك
برحه القزاز او القصير كما يسموها اهل
الطائف ففي تاريخ عريق هنا في السوق نايف
وفي اقبال كبير من اهل الطائف وايضا
الزوار والسياح الذين ياتون للطائف ولا
ننسى نايف انه
الطائف تاريخيا في السعوديه معروفه انها
مصيف
والناس ياتون الى الصيف لكن الجديد والحرص
هنا من المحافظه ومن هيئه السياحه وزاره
السياحه انه تكون ايضا مزار شتوي من خلال
تشجيع بعض الصناعات المحليه وايضا
الزراعات وتكون الطائ ف طول السنه مكان
للزياره والاستمتاع باجوائها وهي طول
السنه بصراحه يا عبد الرحمن بهذا الوصف
اللي وصفته شكرا جزيلا لك
من الطائف مراسل العربيه المتجول في شهر
رمضان في السعوديه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
شكرا يا عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]
فريق بحثي من المركز الوطني لتنميه الحياه
الفطريه في السعوديه من انقاذ سمكتي قرش
عالقتين في احد فخاخ الصيد المهمله نشاهد
[موسيقى]
يتقرب طول الليل مع النهار في الدول
العربيه وفي الدول الاوروبيه يتفاوت طول
الليل مع النهار التفاصيل مع خد الزعاج في
تقويم
[موسيقى]
عندنا ليل وعندنا نهار اذا طلعت الشمس
لانها واذا غابت الشمس جاء الليل والدول
العربيه يتقارب فيهما طول الليل مع النهار
وفي الدول الاوروبيه يتفاوت فيهما طول
الليل مع النهار وعلى القطبين يا ليل يا
نهار هذا على كوكب الارض اما الكون فظلام
دامس فالنهار لا يوجد الا على كوكب الارض
فالموجات الشمسيه تنعكس على الغلاف الغازي
للارض ويتحول الى نهار مرئي فالنهار يولد
من رحم الليل وايه لهم الليل نسلخ منه
النهار فاذا هم مبصرون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فلو ركبنا صاروخ وانطلقنا الى اعماق الكون
ما رايح نشاهد الا ظلام دامس على كثره
الشموس وسنشاهد هذه الشموس على شكل نقاط
كما نشاهد النجوم من على الارض وستكون
حركتنا متعرجه بسبب جاذبيه الاكوان فلو
فتحنا عليهم بابا من السماء فظلوا فيه
يعرجون لقالوا انما سكرت ابصارنا بل نحن
قوم مسحورون فالظلام للكون والنور للارض
لا تحسب ان النور يا زين مني وجهي ترى
يعكس بك النور مني مثل القمر والشمس كانك
وكني اعكس شعاعك واسهر الليل
عنك
[موسيقى]
كتاب الرابعه
الملك سلمان يصدر اوامره باعفاء محافظ
الدرعيه وتكليف ابراهيم السلطان بمهام
الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه الملكيه للرياض
طهران تقول بانها سترد على مقتل ضابطين
بالحرس الثوري في سوريا في الوقت والمكان
المناسبين
وزاره الحج والعمره تعلن تدجين المرحله
الثانيه من تسجيل حجاج الداخل للموسم
القادم
اكتتاب وجود الاسكان في السعوديه يقترب من
تحقيق مليار ريال بعد عشره ايام من اطلاقه
مركز اعتدال يعلن ازاله اكثر من سته
ملايين محتوى متطرف من منصه التليجرام
خلال ثلاثه اشهر
الرابع انتهت شكرا لكم على كرمه ولطف
للمتابعه اعودوا القاكم غدا في رعايه الله
[موسيقى]